this is a CBS News special report on
Gayle King with Tony jacoco and Anthony
Mason is at his home today we have
breaking news for you from Washington
it's our first detailed look at how many
Americans have lost their jobs because
of the corona virus pandemic and it's a
lot people filed unemployment claims
last week we know it's gonna be a lot
we're waiting for that number to come in
to give people an idea of what the
boundaries could be some estimates are
as high as 3.4 million people there has
never been a week in the history of
these numbers more than 50 years where
the number has been more than a million
at the height of the Great Recession the
worst week on record was 665,000 and
they're talking about triple quadruple
that they talked about nearly five times
that so I know it's going to be we just
know it's going to be bad yeah that we
do know because the range of industries
here that are not putting people to work
Hospitality transportation you know the
the you name it and there's about 30
million people in jobs that are
vulnerable right now and the beginning
of these unemployment's began two weeks
ago and it's accelerating
we have our Jill Schlesinger with us
who's going to help talk through these
numbers as 21 states have ordered
non-essential businesses to close other
places are cutting back because they
know they're not going to provide the
services they were they need fewer
workers so Jill this is unlike anything
we've ever seen before we know that even
as we await the official number how bad
do you expect it to be well it looks
like we just got the official number and
it's over three million and I want to
put that in context gang this number is
just beyond what a lot of people thought
just a few days ago we saw the peak of
layoffs weekly claims in 2008-2009 we
never got beyond 700,000 this is the
highest number by a magnitude of four or
five times what does this tell us this
is the first week where we're seeing
claims jumped right in it's such a big
way I think unfortunately we are going
to see subsequent subsequent weeks
follow-on to this this could persist for
a while especially as a lot of
businesses try to take advantage of that
financial life
line that Congress is throwing out right
now you and I went through 2008-2009
covering it together that was a
financial crisis this really is also a
financial crisis in effect isn't it
absolutely I mean a health pandemic has
become a financial pandemic of course we
know that your health is the most
important thing to you but obviously the
knock-on effect of businesses laying
people off furloughing shutting down
this is going to compound the issues I
think that's why when we were talking
about that rescue plan that was
announced and we were talking about it
yesterday and I use the word
lifeline I got a lot of people who
responded to me and said I need that
lifeline and what we are learning now is
more than three million people are in
need of those enhanced unemployment
benefits that extra $600 a week and we
need our small businesses to stay in
business so we've got to see this money
flow to those businesses as quickly as
possible now we keep hearing about
several big-name companies Joe that are
putting out the call to hire thousands
of workers during this time how will
that help offset some of these losses do
you think well I think it will be great
we've heard instacart announced 300,000
jobs we heard 150,000 jobs Amazon a
hundred thousand CVS Walgreens but you
know I tried to do a
back-of-the-envelope calculation
yesterday of all the announcements and
it's about let's say eight or nine
hundred thousand jobs well we have more
than three times as many as those
numbers of new jobs who are on
unemployment right now and so that is
why this is so vitally important we have
got to get money to people who are
impacted we have to do this for the
country we have to do this for the
economy Joe you mentioned it so if
you're one of those and we'll go ahead
Anthony Jill if you're one of those who
thanks Tony if you're one of those
unemployed people how long do you think
it's going to take before you get some
help well I think that the the issue
right now is
the unemployment benefits at the States
has been clogged up and a lot we've got
a lot of information about certain
states where their websites were overrun
hopefully the federal government sending
money to States is going to help beef up
that process I'm a little bit more
concerned with some of the people who
are getting those checks those those
$1,200 and $500 checks for kids because
unless you have direct deposit on
account with the Treasury Department
from the IRS it could take up to a few
maybe four months so if you always got
your tax refund through direct deposit
it's going to be a few weeks you should
be okay
but a few weeks still feels like a long
time again the sooner the better all
right Joe a few weeks does seem like a
long time particularly when we just
learned we've had the worst week for
unemployment claims in the history of
the numbers more than fifty years our
coverage of this economic crisis which
began as a health crisis will continue
on our 24 hour streaming network cbsn
and you can watch it at CBS news.com or
on our CBS news app